In the previous lecture, we
went through examples of
inference involving some
of the variations
of the Bayes rule.
One case that we did not
consider was the case where
the unknown random variable and
the observation are both
continuous.
In this lecture, we will focus
exclusively on an important
model of this kind.
And because we consider only one
specific setting, we will
be able to start it in
considerable detail.
In the model that we consider,
we start with some basic
independent normal
random variables.
Some of them, the Theta j, are
unknown, to be estimated.
And some of them, the
Wi, represent noise.
Our observations, Xi, are linear
functions of these
basic random variables.
In particular, since linear
functions of independent
normal random variables are
normal, the observations are
themselves normal as well.
This is probably the most
commonly used type of model in
all of inference
and statistics.
This is because it is a
reasonable approximation in
many situations.
Also, it has a very clean
analytical structure and a
very simple solution.
For example, it turns out that
the posterior distribution of
each Theta j is itself normal
and that the MAP and LMS
estimates coincide.
This is because the peak of a
normal occurs at the mean.
Furthermore, these estimates
are given by some simple
linear functions of
the observations.
We will go over these facts by
moving through a sequence of
progressively more
complex versions.
We will start with just one
unknown and one observation
and then generalize.
And we will illustrate the
formulation and the solution
through a rather realistic
example where we estimate the
trajectory of an object from
a few noisy measurements.